we're in problem 198
if 1/2 plus 1/3 plus 1/4 is equal to 13
over X which of the following must be an
integer fascinating so let's see what
they're saying
I don't know I'm tempted to just work
through this so if I get a common
denominator here the common denominator
is going to be 12 1/2 is 6 12 plus 4 12
plus 3 12 6 plus 4 plus 3 is 13 so that
equals 13/12 so that tells us that X is
equal to 13 I'm sorry that tells us that
X is equal to 12 all right good
it's the denominator okay so they give
us a couple of choices choice 1 X over 8
is that an integer no 12 divided by 8 is
not an integer it's 1 and 1/2 choice 2x
divided by 12 is that an integer yeah
sure I mean 12 divided by 12 is equal to
1 so that works choice 3 X divided by 24
no 12 X is 12 so X divided by 24 is 1/2
so 2 only is the answer and that is
choice B problem 199 199 and they have
drawn a graph which I will draw so
that's a y-axis there's an x-axis and
that's why and that is X it's in the
rectangular coordinate system above the
line y equals x is the perpendicular
bisector of segment a of segment a B not
shown okay so let me draw this y equals
x graph so start there nope I thought I
was using the line tool but I'm not I'm
using the line tool
that's the y equals x graph y is equal
to X and they draw a point a and either
way the place they drew it it looks like
it's roughly at the point 2 3 I don't
know if that's going to become relevant
to 1/2
ooh three so hey looks like it's at the
point two three
I don't know if that's if we can assume
that okay the line y equals x is a
perpendicular bisector of a B and they
don't show us B and D and the x-axis is
per is the perpendicular bisector of BC
alright not shown if the coordinates of
point a are 2 comma 3 ok we were right a
is 2 comma 3 what are the coordinates of
Point C ok perpendicular bisector means
there some line that's exactly
perpendicular to this line where it
splits it in half right so if you if you
think about it point a is at 2/3 so
where would both be have to be in order
for the line between a and B to be
perpendicular to this line and to be
split directly in half what would be at
the point I mean you could just eyeball
it via the point 3 comma 2 right if
we're at the point 3 comma 2 there's a
lot of I guess intuitive reasons why you
could think that this would be the
perpendicular bisector why why we know y
equals x is a perpendicular bisector the
first is you can see that the slope of
this line you could calculate it if you
want the slope of this line is negative
1 and I know if you remember in in
calculus class but if you have the slope
of one line so the slope of this line is
1 the slope of a perpendicular line will
be the negative inverse of this slope
that's something that hopefully you
learned in calculus or not in algebra a
long time ago so the negative inverse of
1 is negative 1 so this line has a slope
of negative 1 and you could make a bunch
of arguments for why it's equidistant
right it's eat they're both both of
these points are on the same line and
they're equidistant from the point 2
comma 2 so that's why you know that it's
the bisector that this distance is equal
to this distance and frankly on the GMAT
you're doing it fast you don't have to
do a rigorous proof you can eyeball it
you can say oh you know those are going
to be equal I'm just going to take the
mirror image and go on the other side so
this is point B and they tell us that
the x axis the x axis is a perpendicular
bisector of segment BC ok so X is going
to be perpendicular to
this new line so this new line has to be
parallel to the y-axis right so this new
line is going to go like that and
whatever the distance is between B and
the x-axis has to be the distance
between x-axis and C right so B is 2
above the x-axis so C is going to be 2
below the x-axis so that's where C is
and X is at that point X is equal to 3
and so this Y would be equal to negative
2
so C would be so what are the
coordinates of point C 3 negative 2 and
that is choice D interesting problem
problem 200 problem 200 a store
currently charges the same price for
each towel that it sells if the current
price of each towel were to increase by
one dollar 10 fewer of the top towels
could be bought for a hundred and twenty
dollars excluding sales tax ok so if we
increase by priced by one dollar 10
fewer for 120 dollars excluding sales
tax what is the current price of each
towel okay so let's say the current
price of each towel ok so if we take 120
and we divide it by the current price of
each towel we could buy I don't know n
towels right now they're saying that if
we had $120 and if we were to increase
the price by $1 so now the new price is
P plus 1 now I can't buy end towels
anymore they saying I can only buy 10
fewer towels so I can only buy n minus
10 towels now we have two equations with
two unknowns and and well they're not
linear equations but I think we should
be able to solve them one way or the
other so here we get P times n is equal
to 120 P times n is equal to 120 and
here let's see we can multiply we have
120 is equal to P plus 1 times n minus
10 so that's equal to P times n
minus 10p minus 10p right minus 10p plus
n all right plus n minus 10 and so both
of these are equal to 120 so we could
set them to equal to each other right
both of these are equal to 120 so we
could use both of these equations say PN
is equal to PN minus 10p plus n minus 10
so let's see if we can make any headway
here it seems like I might not let's see
so I have I can subtract PN from both
sides so I get 0 is equal to minus 10 P
plus n minus 10 let's see I could add 10
P to both sides and I get 10 P is equal
to n minus 10 okay let's see if I could
well what's N what what what can we
actually I shouldn't have substituted
like this I'm kind of doing it a little
messy but we can do another substitution
right n is equal to 120 over P so that
should help us 10 the real way I should
have done it is well actually no
actually this is I think the easiest way
to do it 10 P and is 120 over P a lot of
times you just have to go forth with the
algebra and see what happens minus 10
and let's multiply both sides equation
by P so you get 10 is equal sorry 10 P
squared is equal to 120 minus 10p let's
divide both sides by 10 just to get rid
of them so you get P squared is equal to
12 minus P let's take these onto the
left hand side so you get P squared plus
P minus 12 is equal to 0 we have a
quadratic we can just factor it that is
P plus 4 times P minus 3 is equal to 0
right what two numbers when you add them
equal plus 1 right the core the
coefficient there and when you multiply
them equal negative 12 and that's just
practice you've got in algebra doing
that so this P plus 4 times P minus 3 so
he could he be -4 or P could be equal to
3 and P can't be -4 unless he was giving
away the towels he was paying people to
take the towels which isn't the case we
assuming that price is positive so the
price had to be $3 which luckily enough
after doing all that algebra is one of
the choices choice C next question 201 I
think I have time to do this one 201 if
the sum of n consecutive integers is 0
okay sum of n integers is equal to 0 and
they're consecutive consecutive this is
my ad hoc notation which of the
following must be true n consecutive
integers is 0 n must be an even number n
is even so let's think a lot about like
our even an odd type of talk so we know
that an even plus an even is even and we
know that an odd plus an odd is also
even all right you could prove it to
yourself you could try a bunch of
numbers or if you just write an odd as
2k plus 1 and you add it to another to M
plus 1 to K that becomes 2 times k plus
M plus 2 so that's an even number right
it's divisible by 2 so an odd plus an
odd is even and so the only way you're
going to get an odd number is if you
have an even plus an odd now the only
way you're going to have an even plus an
odd so we're summing n consecutive
numbers right so I don't know let's call
it you know number 1 plus number 2 plus
number 3 let's think about it a couple
of different ways if if this number is
odd then this number is obviously even
and then this number is odd right now if
we're taking the sum of an even number
if we're taking it a sum of an even
number if n is even we're gonna get the
same number of evens and odds right
we're going to have so for EM and could
be too right if n could be two we're
going to have one even and one odd no
matter what right this could be I this
could be even or this could be even in
this could be odd and if n is 2 which is
an even number we can very easy this you
know an odd plus and even is an odd
number so they say if the sum of n
consecutive integers is 0 the sum of N
oh you know what I completely missed
that point let me continue this in the
next video